I've read that you that you were a big
fan of LeBron James growing up obviously
uh can you talk about how special it is
for you to play against him tomorrow in
a match up like that and also uh you've
beat in Boston Milwaukee now the Lakers
with LeBron does he feel kind of the the
final monster of a video game or
something like he's just standing there
the final end oh he say like the final
boss uh yeah no I think the first part
of question like like any kid born in
2000 LeBron was my favorite player
growing up you know what I mean um and
it's it's hard it's hard for him not to
be for for a lot of us and so I you know
growing up I was a Cavs fan then a Heat
fan then a Cavs fan again then a Lakers
fan before I got drafted you know it's
just how how it went and so to to be
able to compete against him in the
championship is uh kind of like a story
story book a little bit and it's going
to be a lot of fun um but that's the
great part about being in the NBA is
getting to compete against you know your
idols on a on a nightly basis so I I
really look forward to that and then as
far as the second part of your question
I just think um for us we're not
supposed to be here and nobody expected
us to be here we've been probably looked
at to lose the majority of our
tournament games the Philly game we
weren't supposed to win uh uh Boston
game we definitely weren't supposed to
win Milwaukee we definitely weren't
supposed to win so um that's just been
part of the the the the story book of
this and it's been a lot of fun and uh
but it's not done yet you know we got to
be prepared to go tomorrow and approach
that game the right
way